[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
nous allons essayer d'éclairer
l'actualité on va parler de plusieurs
sujets on va parler notamment de laïcité
on va parler des liens de d'eric zemmour
l'extrême droite on va parler aussi de
l'anniversaire du général de gaulle qui
est omniprésent dans la politique
française on va parler aussi de
politique du logement avec mes invités
raphaël mata de vidéos bonjour je
faisais de maître de conférences à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
de droit public et vous êtes un des
fondateurs aussi des surligneurs oui
j'ai commencé à écrire effectivement
vous débutez surligneurs oui voilà vingt
charles lajaunie bonjour bonjour vous
êtes éditeur on va présenter dans
quelques instants le bain dernière par
les films de votre maison d'édition
quentin des mers bonjour vous êtes
étudiant vous êtes vous êtes aussi
conseiller municipal de guyancourt et
vous appartenait au parti communiste
français
geoffrey meyer bonjour si vous êtes
avocat à 20,5 vous êtes secrétaire de la
conférence du stage exactement voilà
jeune avocat donc tout à fait un ça fait
et bien vous avez vous avez une avocate
alors qu' un peu plus de métier si je
peux aussi qui est avec nous c'est
florence marcadet choqué bonjour vous
êtes
vous êtes également avocate au barreau
de versailles et spécialiste de droit du
travail
alors on va apporter un certain nombre
de sujets quant à des maires je vais
commencer avec vous parce que vous
vouliez nous parler d'une manifestation
qui a lieu le 10 novembre mercredi au
ministère du logement et à l'appel d'un
certain nombre de maires et d'élus de
gauche et ça concerne les logements
sociaux oui c'est un élément qui est
extrêmement important c'est ma
délégation notamment sur l'observatoire
de l'habitat je parle notamment des 50%
de hlm qu'on assure guyancourt
on a un problème en ile de france c'est
qu'on a une crise du logement depuis
très longtemps des gens n'arrivent pas à
se loger en ile de france et un des
problèmes pour le logement social c'est
qu'il ya aujourd'hui un gap de 2 à 3 3
fois le prix entre le social et privé
que je ne peuvent plus sortir du social
et le solde donc joue ce rôle l'a
finalement du logement pas trop cher il
permet de garantir finalement l'égalité
sur le territoire où tout le monde peut
vivre proche son travail proche de la
culture en centre-ville aussi même en
ile de france et ça c'est possible donc
on à la loi sru qui fait qu'on a on
devrait atteindre 1 5% dans chaque ville
où l'eau est serré et ça c'est dit oui
il faudrait 25 ans dans le logement
sociaux après ça mais je voulais
rappeler un autre chiffre important
c'est que 70 % des franciliens sont
éligibles au logement social donc on a
vraiment en fait cet objectif français
de dire que le chalet ne sait pas que
pour les pauvres c'est aussi pour les
classes moyennes ceci pour tous ceux qui
veulent se loger pour pas trop cher et
donc des villes comme le scellier bbc en
a 70 % et 25 % à base ça veut dire qu'il
a posé des problèmes quand on parle
notamment de ghettoïsation c'est le fait
qu'on ne construise pas assez le
logement social et donc on va voir que
les plus pauvres les plus est
prioritaire c'est légitime qui soit les
prioritaires parce que c'est eux qui ont
le plus de mal de se loger qu'ils
puissent accéder comme ça au logement et
donc nous qui avons 50% et d'autres
villes qui jouent aussi le jeu d'avoir
plus de logements sociaux il permet de
cette mixité en proximité de paris et
permettra à plein temps qui pourrait pas
devenir qui pourrait pas vivre ici en
fait de vie dans une belle banlieue
proche de paris proche du travail proche
de la culture et ce qui est annoncé
c'est qu'a priori il ya des menaces en
voulant mettre un plafond finalement
dans les villes qui seraient à 40% par
exemple qui empêcherait donc les villes
de vous construire plus de 40 % de
logements sociaux et ça veut dire que
nous on serait pointé du doigt nous dit
à 50% comme d'autres villes un peu plus
encore
c'est bien la turquie et des villes qui
est 50% des hauts de canet un peu moins
de 25 2 parce qu'il ya un certain nombre
de communes je crois vraiment comme une
enfance qui ne respectent pas la loi
donc eu au moins de 25% est ce que c'est
bien fait pas des ghettos c'est comme ça
si on fait des villes à 60 % de
logements sociaux est d'accord sur une
chose s'est il faut que l'état tape sur
des villes mais pas sur les villes qui
ont 50% ou plus mais sur les villes qui
au contraire ont pas les 25 c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des ghettos de
riches qui sont créés autour de paris où
on exclut les gens par le plus du mètre
carré en fait c'est simple si on est co
propriétaire et que le prix du mètre
carré est très cher on est sûr qu'on va
se retrouver entre nous dans notre petit
milieu sans les pauvres on pourrait dire
au sens ans les infirmières sont les
profs sans ceux qui ont les les revenus
normaux on pourrait dire et donc il ya
un vrai enjeu pour nous de dire il faut
taper sur la question du logement mais
sur les villes qui sont carencés et pas
sur les villes qui jouent le jeu de la
mixité alors il faut préciser qu
emmanuelle wargon qui est la ministre du
logement a annoncé la pérennisation de
cette voie c'est rue il y avait un débat
il se disait peut-être qu'on va revenir
dessus elle a annoncé cette
pérennisation c'est de dire c'est 25% de
deux logements cette obligation de 27 %
de logements sociaux ceux qui ne
respectent pas évidemment en principe
d'aidé enda c'est ça
voilà ce qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
non à ce qui est vrai c'est là la
question du logement était très
importante et je rejoins change encore
de quentin rejoint quentin sur la
question de la alors je suis pas au
courant sur le projet de sur le projet
de plafonner par contre là je suis
d'accord sur le fait que l'état doive
prendre ses responsabilités en ce qui
concerne la sanction concernant vers les
communes qui ne respectent pas là les 20
et 25% ça c'est un premier point un
autre point important c'est que il ne
faut pas oublier que les communes et ça
s'efface et le juriste qui parle désolé
il faut pas oublier que les communes ont
la compétence en matière de logement
social donc c'est elle qui doivent
développer leurs pôles propre politique
de logement social l'état doit aider
évidemment mais ce sont les communes qui
sont libres qui sont le principe de
libre administration des collectivités
elles doivent justement développer leurs
propres politiques publiques en matière
de logement et de logement social
maintenant il ya un point qui n'est
peut-être pas abordé dans votre
manifestation dans votre
problématique c'est qu'il ya beaucoup
aussi de logements vacants
et ça moi j'ai un taux de logements
souvent public indien des logements
publics mais aussi des logements qui
sont désaffectés d'une certaine manière
et il faut bien prendre en considération
image et une étudiante qui a travaillé
là-dessus l'année dernière
l'état à mener une enquête une recension
de tous les logements sociaux logements
vacants en france il ya un nom il ya
plusieurs millions plusieurs millions de
logements vacants et le problème c'est
que réhabiliter des logements qui se
sont désinfectés coûte beaucoup trop
cher et donc c'est vrai que d'états qui
l'ont pas aux groupes et aux femmes sont
absolument est en réalité moi je vais
souvent en vacances en dans l'ariège il
ya un nombre incalculable de logements
qui sont vacants il ya des maisons
inhabitées parce que ça coûte trop cher
pour les propriétaires de les
réhabiliter et donc là on pourrait
peut-être trouvé un moyen il l'état
pourrait peut-être aidé et ça ça
pourrait être un élément l'état pourrait
aider à la réhabilitation de ces
logements vacants qui permettrait
peut-être n'ont pas de construire des
logements sociaux mais de leva de
permettre une de remplir ces deux
mauvais des logements voit l'art se doit
alors cela dit c'est vrai que si vous
habitez oui au coup vous allez dans
l'ariège vous avez longtemps b mais en
ile de france et beaucoup s'y de
logements vacants absolument non a gagné
et des logements et privés et publics
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que ça me
comprends pas très bien pourquoi l'état
d'ailleurs
ne facilite pas qu'on la leur le
réaménagement sauf pour une question
comme ne nous dit que de deux coups un
jab oui pour répondre à monsieur est
effectivement beaucoup beaucoup de
logements vacants mais c'est aussi très
compliqué effectivement pour un
propriétaire parce que il ya aussi un
niveau de confort de normes et deux
choses qui font que ça ça renchérit
considérablement généralement alors
c'est vrai que c'est très bien de
pouvoir assurer à tout le monde d'être à
22 degrés sans aucun problème sans qu'il
y ait le moins de votre lecteur mais
c'est quasiment mission impossible ou
sinon je viens ça va être un puits sans
fond donc ça c'est de la première chose
donc c'est très compliqué cette
abondance de normes est ce ce confort
démentiel que qu'on exige partout de
tous et et à faible coût pour l'oeuvre
pour l'occupant et puis deuxièmement on
parle beaucoup d'écologie et que de
continuer à vouloir regrouper le plus de
monde possible dans la région parisienne
ça me paraît une aberration totale mais
une folie une folie de continuer à
vouloir faire venir les gens tout près
de leur boulot tout près de la culture
etc ok y'a il ya d'autres choses bien
que recul que paris on peut aussi
essayer de des idées
politiques
l'aménagement du territoire cette
monstruosité parisienne s'est dénoncé
c'est ça le véritable problème alors
après on pourra toujours effectivement
manifesté pour dire construisons des
logements faisons venir des pauvres des
demies pauvres des cars de pauvre à côté
des risques ça ne changera rien au
problème ces changements il ya trop de
monde à paris de toute façon il faut
désengorger ces sept cas madame hidalgo
fut construit l'usiné lors des faits
politiques ne parlons même pas grêle de
nouvelles vous
flosse de la cad et choqué
il ya peut-être trop de monde à paris
mais il ya énormément de vacances à
paris et qui appartiennent à
l'état et à la ville de paris donc ça
c'est quand même très choquant que tous
aient un logement vacant notamment la
r&d paix qu'est la régie immobilière de
la ville de paris à détiennent gère
enfin gère du vide sur de nouveaux
appartements nous faut déjà l'état
balaye devant sa porte avant le privé
balaye devant sa porte et sûre sur les
sur les logements sociaux ce qui secret
ce qui serait bien c'est d'avoir des
logements mixtes plutôt que de faire que
du social pur et dur sur ces immeubles
et la mixité manque beaucoup d'ailleurs
sur les logements qu'ils peuvent être
faits en périphérie d'un
jeu c'est sinon on va à nouveau parc et
légendes en un an dans le même immeuble
et faire une mixité de toute classe je
serais quand même très beau et pour que
les gens puissent justement se connaître
se parler et pas marqué des gens à
droite à gauche
très rapidement parce que de toute façon
presque tout a déjà été dit en réalité
j'étais complètement d'accord avec vous
lorsque vous faisiez remarquer à raphaël
que lorsqu'on vit en alors lorsqu'on
travaille en région parisienne c'est
peut-être compliqué d'envoyer les gens
en ariège et c'est sans doute la
difficulté de cette politique là c'est
que de prendre les choses de manière
globale alors que on a de vraies
situations qui sont régionalisée et je
vous rejoins là aussi il ya absolument
trop de monde à paris et c'est compliqué
d'envisager ce taux de 25% sur un plan
national
alors qu'en réalité on voit qu'il ya des
problèmes de concentration tant sur le
plan des logements que deux
concentration et de difficultés
économiques puisque en réalité les gens
viennent là vous ont du travail la
maison de la culture là ils ont une
activité et c'est sans doute là encore
j'ai rejoint finalement je vais d'accord
avec tout le monde au temps 2 1 c'est
bien les miens self et la seconde
au moins bien que je sois avocat je ne
suis pas notamment est nécessairement
pour le confit et c'est parfaitement
c'est parfaitement exact sur le fait qu'
il ya un vrai problème derrière cette
politique du logement d'aménagement
global du territoire alors après il ya
une autre question enfin c'est vrai que
merkel est ce que parler parler de
mixité il ya dans les revendications à
des des élus qui vous qui vont
manifester devant le ministère du
logement d'idées par exemple d'inclure
des logements sociaux dans des des 6 me
priver de quartiers résidentiels alors
ce que c'était une bonne oeuvre comme ça
une bonne idée en soi mais il ya des
gens qui ont payé assez cher leur
logement qui se disent si on accueille
d'aider des logements sociaux dans nos
immeubles ça va faire effondrer le prix
le prix bon disons après tout c'est
peut-être une sorte d'égoïsme mais ça
peut se comprendre il ya vu si l'idée
saugrenue de d'anne hidalgo une de plus
qui avait racheté des appartements
absolument somptueux dans les plus beaux
quartiers de paris pour les transformer
en habitat social sur le principe c'est
très bien mais sauf que en pratique il
aurait mieux fait de vendre ses
appartements somptueux au prix du mètre
carré absolument astronomiques et avec
cet argent là de créer des logements
bien ailleurs mais c'est juste un espèce
de 2,2 coup de coude annonces pour des
voiliers on est bien mais nous on va
vers des c'est vrai qu'un fédérer les
changements sociaux dans le xvième
économiquement aucun sens aux eaux dans
des haies il ya des villes d'ailleurs
dans les yvelines
à l'ouest enfin dans la région de
versailles d'état qui ne font pas les
25% de deux logements sociaux et les
quand vous parlez avec les maires ils
sont très ennuyée par ça parce que en
effet ils ont une population plutôt
bourgeoise et qui regarde alors c'est çà
et là une sorte d'égoïsme en effet assez
formés
on peut comprendre un peu cet argument
là non quand un mois j'étais d'accord
sur l'idée qu'il faut casser les ghettos
en france et quand on tourne à un ghetto
qui s'est formé il faut essayer de le
casser moi je et le nous pouvons
regretter autriche je voulais y est tous
les ghettos sont a cassé donc les
ghettos de riches aussi ce sont aussi à
casser à ouvrir il faut que ces gens
aussi sorte un petit peu du carcan la
qualifie ce pack le xvième où le 7e
arrondissement soit à l'image de la
france il faudrait c'est bien de les
ouvrir à c'est vrai mais l'exemple de
donc c'est monsieur ian brossât
l'adjoint au logement sûr comme si comme
à paris et qui fait un travail
remarquable ils ont beaucoup augmenté
leurs taux et ils font ce travail de
répartition aussi à dire que notamment
la un bâtiment de l'armée s'il me trompe
pas qui vient d'être rénovée en septième
avec yves accueillir 250 logements
sociaux ont fait de la mixité l'idée
c'est bien de dire que on va pas on se
plaint de dire que le 19e le 20e serait
se disent envahi ghetto mais en même
temps l'autre façon l'ouest ne veut pas
que garder l'humour sociaux - yahia et
gaines électriques pack est pas rentable
et donc la bonne la bonne solution c'est
de mieux répartir et donc aussi de faire
des hlm dans 16e aussi dans 7e c'est pas
de la haine du riche de faire ça c'est
juste l'idée de il faut répartir tous
les quartiers doivent prendre leur part
aux six logements sociaux et je voulais
juste rappeler aussi pour la mixité
quand on parle de mixité sociale gili 70
% des franciliens sont éligibles faut
pas oublier qu'ils aient pas le logement
social il ya trois types de logements
sociaux les baies l'aï les pl us les pls
avec des tarifs différents qui fait que
les mails les gens qui vivent les mêmes
même même immeuble au débat ils peuvent
payer ne pas le peuple peut ne pas payer
le même prix en fonction de leurs
revenus il ya déjà une mixité est que
quand on fait un travail urbanistique
homme habillé en cours par exemple on va
avoir plusieurs bâtiments pareils un
privé un social en accession par exemple
des bâtiments à l'extérieur sont les
mêmes les gens vivent à côté il vit dans
la même école ils font tout ensemble
justice ont pas le même bâtiment ils
paient pas les mêmes primes c'est normal
et non pas les mêmes revenus et donc
payer chacun payé en fonction de ce
qu'il peut payer et à la fin de mon
vivant vie ensemble et c'est comme ça
que je vois un peu le vivre ensemble en
tout cas niveau local quant à la mixité
c'est vrai qu autrefois fin de même dans
les immeubles bourgeois
parisien par exemple mais il y avait les
bourgeois au deuxième étage et puis plus
du monte
charge et la concierge au rez de
chaussée
quand on parle aussi beaucoup j sery si
on appelle son vendeur donc loin des
quartiers de paris le plus de chambres
de bonne et le grès jeu plus encore de
gardien est concierge et c'est donc
c'est vrai que cette année on a
probablement un peu perdu cette mixité
qui existait dans l'histoire qua non
même si mixité avec la question se pose
aussi de savoir est-ce qu'il suffit de
vivre à côté pour être vraiment utile
est ce que le bâtiment se magne a été
vraiment mixte nord oui oui enfin guido
et sa 6ème jamais content
à chaque fois qu'on apporte un pêcheur a
oui mais quand même
j'aime bien aussi les bâtiments
haussmanniens y avait été rejetée que tu
râles pas de problème mais si la
question derrière de l'école et des
institutions si les enfants vit dans un
même bâtiment ou à côté mais on parlait
même école par exemple n'ya pas dixit et
donc c'est un symbole anonyme tout va
ensemble et ont donc manifestation
mercredi soir le coin 18 heures 18
heures devant chez madame emmanuelle
wargon ministre du logement
on va passer aux eaux d'un thème qui
était assez intéressant qu'il tire qui
qui rejoint la question de la laïcité de
la conception de notre conception de la
dignité c'est ce débat sur la campagne
sur le lot hidjab pourquoi la france se
fâchent
[Musique]
assez d'une campagne européenne
alors on sait pas très bien je crois que
c est ce que c'est la commission ou est
ce que c'est
c'est le conseil de paroisse du conseil
de l'europe mais la commission avait
donné son accord je crois que c'est la
commission de la faune l'élection de
zemmour
bon ça c'est cette chose mais c'est
alors donc voilà si on traduit ça veut
dire la beauté dans la diversité comme
la liberté dans le globe c'est dire
c'était quand fans sur la diversité
campagne européenne ça a suscité la
colère de la france je crois que
l'allemagne aussi d'ailleurs
et la campagne a été a été retiré mais
c'est intéressant parce que on voit
comme en europe on a des conceptions
assez différente
de la liberté de la laïcité non oui ce
nissan ans oui alors c'est une campagne
qui a été une promotion du conseil de
l'europe avec le soutien de la
commission la commission européenne donc
les deux les deux grandes institutions
européennes sont visiblement de concert
sur cette campagne publicitaire
alors j'avoue à titre personnel je ne
parle pas du jeu c'est pas le jeu ce
n'est pas le juriste qui parle c'est le
citoyen je préfère séparer j'ai été
assez surpris pour pas dire autre chose
par cette campagne pub local m
aujourd'hui on va dire que c'est qu'on
va dire choquée par cette
juriste eux pour avoir la même
appréciation que le citoyen d'ailleurs
oui tout à fait mais alors c'est vrai
que la laïcité
si on a une conception large la laïcité
c'est que tout le monde doit vivre sa
religion ou sa non religion tout en
toute liberté donc on n'y a pas de
discrimination pas de pas de persécution
si on va un petit peu plus loin donc
effectivement si on a un regard assez
assez libre une femme pourrait libyen
pourrait porter le hidjab ou le foulard
dans la rue autrement maintenant en
faire la promotion je pense que c'est ça
c'est faire la promotion parce que
pourquoi alors pourquoi parler de 8
jamais on pourrait très bien parler
d'autre chose parce que là on se
focalise sur le sur le foulard on
pourrait se focaliser sur d'autres
signes identitaires communautaire et moi
ce que je trouve assez assez délirant
géanges employer ce terme de la part du
conseil de l'europe renaud vincent n'est
pas là
un an couronne me dégoûte mais
assez délirant c'est que on promeut un
un style de vie et c'est à dire que là
où le conseil de l'europe va promouvoir
quelque chose qui est un signe
ostentatoire j'emploie le terme quand
même un signe ostentatoire
d'appartenance à une religion comme si
c'était le seul vecteur de liberté et ça
je trouve que c'est assez dangereux de
la part du conseil de l'europe parce qu
on se focalise sur une religion alors
que justement elle devrait être occupé
aucune munich
c'est à dire qu'on devrait pouvoir la
liberté c'est le hidjab ça pourrait être
aussi d'autres d'autres signent donc
promouvoir ces points 101 printemps un
premier élément de réflexion promouvoir
le hidjab je trouve que c'est que c'est
dangereux de la part du conseil d'europe
parce que ça ça ça conduit finalement à
accentuer les ressentis qu'on a en
france mais ce que ça peu probable et
j'avoue à ce que ça dit oh faut tolérer
des différences on est on est tous ceux
européens puisque la série de l'europe
alors vous allez on est tous français et
on peut avoir des ddd mode de vie
différent
c'est cette conception de la laïcité qui
est en effet ça a choqué un joli valérie
pécresse a protesté gabriel un talent
pour tester laurence rossignol ces deux
traits de gauche a protesté donc il ya
eu une protestation assez globale mais
c'est aussi notre conception de la
laïcité qui est pas la même que celle
causée par au lendemain d'autres pays
européens non mais c'est parce que c'est
parfaitement exact c'est vrai qu'en
france nous avons une conception
particulière de la laïcité que nous
partageons avec finalement peu d'autres
pays européens oui parce que en réalité
c'est une publicité qui a été enfin
publicité oui on va dire publicité qui a
été à l'origine
faits faite par le conseil de l'europe
est vrai que le conseil de l'europe ça
regroupe 47 états membres qui ont tous
dû vision particulière de la laïcité la
laïcité en france c'est pas la tête non
ces quelque 47 le conseil de l'ordre un
conseiller de laurent des français de
leurs 47 et la laïcité en france en
réalité de la façon dont on la conçoit
c'est pas la négation même de la
religion ou de la liberté au lieu c'est
simplement dire que dans l'espace public
il doit y avoir une forme de neutralité
qui ne doit pas aboutir à la promotion
d'une religion et en ça c'est vrai que
lorsque de notre point de vue franco
français lorsque l'on voit ça
nécessairement ça crée des remous alors
je vais me permettre d'avoir peut-être
cette interprétation alors en éclairage
peut-être alors un peu plus juridique là
où c'est très étonnant cette publicité
qui a été fait par le conseil de
l'europe c'est que conseil de l'europe
il a deux chevilles ouvrières parce
qu'il a quand même pour fonction
principale de promouvoir notamment les
droits et les libertés fondamentales en
europe il a deux chevilles ouvrières
pour cela que sont la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et sont
l'émanation qui est la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme et la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme elle
s'est déjà prononcé sur le hidjab elle
s'est déjà prononcée aussi sur d'autres
signes religieux et concernant l'espace
public et la cour européenne des droits
de l'homme avait dit de manière très
claire que ce qui devait prévaloir entre
la liberté religieuse et le principe de
laïcité puisqu'en réalité on est
toujours sur la confrontation est le
rapport entre les deux c'est le principe
de laïcité et donc c'est étonnant et on
se demandait quand on se demande ce qui
a bien pu se passer avec cette publicité
du conseil de l'europe lorsqu'on sait
que sa cheville ouvrière ces émanations
font prévaloir l'asie sur la liberté
religieuse le principe de laïcité en ce
sens qu'il doit respecter une forme de
neutralité dans l'espace public
florence mercredi sauter
alors moi personnellement effectivement
j'ai été assez choqué même si le but de
du conseil de l'europe c'est de lutter
contre les discriminations contre la
haine pour la conscience la liberté de
conscience serait liberté de la religion
et ce qui me choque beaucoup dans le
dans la promotion et dans l'intitulé
c'est au lieu de dire que la femme la
liberté de porter le hidjab il dit que
la liberté est dans le wild c'est vrai
c'est la formulation est formée
cette publicité entre guillemets c'est
très choquant dans la mesure où
peut-être que c'est plus une
revendication
de 2002 nom de l'islam en disant que la
liberté est dans le midget quand on voit
toutes ces femmes qui sont soumises à
une pression contraintes y en a
certaines qui a effectivement le porte
de manière libre mais une grande
majorité de femmes peuvent être aussi
battu un voire même assassiner si elles
portent pas le windsor donc la liberté
c'est pas le hidjab et on se demande
quand même s'il n'y a pas derrière aussi
une pression islamiste un espèce des
temps d'arrêt une instrumentalisation
politique
du conseil de l'europe qui s'est pas non
plus effectivement ce qu'il ya derrière
composé par là où c'était probablement
une bonne idée en allant sur les droits
de blogs de manière générale et pour
lutter tous les relations on est pris
pour un faire valoir la tolérance
effectivement donc au départ l'idée est
bonne mais à l'arrivée trouve que c'est
une catastrophe quant à dr et puis
j'entends mais moi j'ai pas grand chose
à rajouter sur ça je suis d'accord aussi
avec ses cheveux attachés à la laïcité à
la française on pourrait dire oui et
donc lavées si vous n'êtes pas là
mais c'est vrai que j'ai envie de dire
au nom des athées
rarement de nous apparemment pose pas
beaucoup de problèmes nous c'est
toujours les débats religion pour ce
jour un petit peu a pour ses différentes
communautés on pense jamais la grande
communauté de france qu'a priori c'est
des athées ce qu'apparemment d'année
sondage a montré que 51 % des français
ne croient plus aux ou ne croient plus
en dieu mais c'est la première fois
qu'il ya une majorité aussi nous sommes
majoritaires et donc
et des cadeaux comme tu dit excusez moi
vous êtes euros au parti communiste qui
jusque jusqu alors soudé jean luc
mélenchon dans les dents les
présidentielles là fabien roussel va
probablement être candidat il se
présente est-ce que c'est pas une des
indes et des désaccords que vous avez à
gauche justement avec le avec la france
insoumise cette trappe ce rapport
justement à la laïcité bien sûr que la
question de derrière l'universalisme
pourrait dire aussi la question de
de quelle tradition sa capture tradition
à gauche on pourrait dire non ça qu'on
n'est plus la vieille tradition
notamment avec le féminisme par exemple
sur la question autour des femmes et des
ports religion en général on a toujours
cette vision comme de l'adie nations
derrière donc mais même si on n'est pas
contre le port du voile dans public on
admet quand même tout à fait très
largement la nation qui est d'ailleurs
un port au milieu basse que la religion
est l'opium du peuple et donc c'est pas
tout ça c'est la position des africains
se brise mais et c'est pour ça aussi
c'est une des raisons c'est pas la seule
donnée en désaccord mais c'est une des
raisons qui font qu'on n'est pas on a
aussi de nos différences aux divergences
on se retrouve sur pas mal de sujets il
faut le dire mais sur certains sujets où
il ya des divergences dans famille
oui comment ne pas être d'accord avec
tout ce qui a été dit sûr c'est que la
fij et personne ne défend la salustro
ces options sont anglo saxon de laïcité
elle sourit la difficulté c'est excusez
moi je l'entends et c'est vrai que ma
consoeur as parfaitement raison là
dessus c'est dans le message en réalité
si le message avait été ou un autre et
que
exactement la liberté des badauds mais
on aurait sans doute on aurait sans
doute une position différente si le
message avait été différent n'y aurait
pas eu d' affiches parce que c'est pas
un hasard c'est pas une erreur c'est une
volonté bien claires et nettes de faire
passer ce message là et pas un autre et
c'est vrai que au delà de ce qu'on peut
penser
il n'y a pas de secret sur ce que je
peux conseil du port du voile du hidjab
donc on va pas revenir là dessus mais il
ya une influence de la turquie s'est tue
c'est une évidence et c'est ça aussi le
scandale après
on va dire aux gens que l'europe c'est
génial etc c'est à juste titre les gens
vont dire si l'argent de l'europe sert à
ça franchement mais sait on nous prend
pour des dingues enfin je veux dire
c'est une pure folie sahpresa cas ça
remarque-t-il maintenant laissez ce que
tout le monde sait ce que tout le monde
va foncer
c'est juste il n'y a pas un seul point
positif dans cette campagne d'affichage
mais pas un seul et on avoue cherchait
partout je dirais peut-être la photo est
jolie je sais pas celle-là cette photo
est très belle oui ce n'est pas la faute
aux
photographes c'est tout mais voilà c'est
peu quand même mais célébré célébrer de
diversité célébrer la diversité
en cela n'a aucun sens et c'est ridicule
et c'est vrai que sélectionne une réelle
difficulté en moi j'ai lu quelques
articles sur ce sujet là et il était
précisé que des associés alors
l'association qui a été à l'origine de
cette pub serait et qui a incité le
conseil de l'europe à la sphère serait
alors un petit peu phagocyté par
d'autres associations notamment deux
frères musulmans et c'est vrai que si ça
c'est vrai c'est aussi ça aboutit à cela
sacré à poser un problème problème
bon en fait le oui pardon l'affluence
est un petit mot sur ce que vous dites
confrères ces
actions vous verrez que la femme nous le
sommes peut-être un petit peu moins
pardon oui oui absolument non je disais
que mon confrère avait parfaitement
raison parce que j'ai lu aussi elle en
remettant du conditionnel que ce serait
une association qui s'appelle hainard
qui a pour étendard la lutte contre le
racisme et miga mais derrière le ménage
il ya le ccf qu'il est dissous par le
gouvernement français pour sa
participation dans la suite dans
l'assassinât de samuel paty et lennar
perçoit 1 millions d'euros depuis 2012
et il semblerait qu'effectivement ce
soit lennar qu'ils aient pu
instrumentaliser le conseil de l'europe
sur ce sujet et sur cette promotion oui
là c'est plus grave en effet
cette
florence a tout à fait raison mais ce
qui est extrêmement inquiétant c'est que
soient les fonctionnaires européens ne
se sont pas aperçus qu'ils étaient
instruits instrumentalisé et là alors là
c'est la panique à bord soit ils le sont
et c'est encore filles dans les deux cas
et encore une fois il ya aucun aveu les
deux seuls les des deux solutions sont
absolument nécessaires
pour cela doit aller dit qu'on pouvait
imaginer alors vous disiez ça va faire
monter c'est vous
c'est du pain bénit même tous les
candidats de droite vainqueur et tous
les gens qui parlent de l'immigration et
qui va être effectivement on veut
le souhaitait le regretter mais peu
importe mais ça va être un des sujets de
la présidentielle et que là c'est du
pain béni pour les gens qui quittent le
voc s'éteint l'un des gros sujets les ja
jubilé bien évidemment présent c'est
enfin actuellement en tout cas
où la vue avec le débat de d4 enfin des
cinq prétendants à l'investiture droite
il va oublier ce tir ou non
celui qui a le plus parlé quasiment
enfin en tout cas qu'avait non mais
c'est un sujet puisqu'ils sont tous
quasiment d'accord enfin je veux dire
nous avons pris la position sur le voile
ce qu'il de faux quand ils sont enfants
pas enfin bon oui bon après c'est sont
pas non plus d'importance à ça parce que
ce qui serait tragique c'est de réduire
le problème de l'immigration juste au
problème du voile donc je pense que là
il faut deux choses peut-être garder
c'est quoi ces conclusions à différents
et que ce qu'on peut noter deux de façon
claire c'est que l'irruption de zemmour
dans le dans le champ politique
a poussé beaucoup de candidats à enfin
prendre d
avoir une opinion et avoir une idée sur
l'immigration bien l'excellent enfin
qu'on peut discuter mais
oui
oui enfin parce que c'est un problème
importance je pense pas qu'on puisse
faire l'économie de ce débat après ça va
dans un sens ça va dans l'eau ça c'est
les discussions politiques mais on peut
pas dire que c'est pas un problème qui
n'est pas un souci c'est pas quelque
chose à régler donc ça ça me paraît
évident et au moins c'est un effet
positif ou à la
surgissement d'eric zemmour c'est
celui-là parce que - et peut-être qu
enfin le le président macron va un peu
se s'intéresser au sujet et nous pas
être là depuis cinq ans à nous dire
alors à parce ce discours des mureaux
mais sinon ça fait quand même cinq ans
qu'on attend des décisions qu'on attend
sa prise de position qui ne viendra
jamais et j'ai peur qu'elles ne viennent
pas non plus là donc alors justement on
va parler d'eux après on pourrait
discuter sur l'a7 vision de la france
c'est ce que c'est pas une vision un peu
étriqué un peu de replis sur soi même un
peu vieillotte non premier temps les
trois sets face à la taille cette france
qui se veut plus accueillir que kick
boxing
lui alors globe les chiffres de
l'immigration sont peut-être pas aussi
catastrophique que ce condiment fabre
c'est en abordant un dossier qu'on
n'entend pas le relativement peu c'est
justement pour la candidature d'eric
zemmour c'est le soutien de l'extrême
extrême droite
[Musique]
d'abord peut-être oui un poids sur
l'électorat de d'eric zemmour par
rapport à marine le panier ideye des
études la thur on voit que c'est un
doctorat moins populaire que l'électorat
traditionnel du rassemblement national
et le revendique d'ailleurs examen en
disant belle pour être élu il faut à la
fois le vote populaire mais aussi il
faut le vote des de la bourgeoisie en
gros seins et c'est vrai que et c'est
vrai qu'il la bourgeoisie de leleu
rejoint un peu on a déjà un petit à
petit revenu à versailles zemmour et il
y avait dans le public par exemple une
dame je propose de la regarder ça c'est
intéressant parce que c'est l'un des
électorats d'eric zemmour
je veux dire d'abord très intelligent
ensuite il vise qu'à voyons si dit ce
qu'on pense depuis
96 50 ans quoi mais on peut pas on
pouvait pas parler vous comprenez on
pouvait pas parler c'est ça dont qui
parle pour nous et c'est extraordinaire
parce que du coup la télévision ils sont
complètement coincé je terminerai pas à
la télévision gps est vide de sens vous
venez d'où la
[Rires]
voilà c'était versailles et c'était
bourgeois s'étaient scindés électorale
des risées vous c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs parce que ça ça c'est plutôt
un lectorat est ce que c'est ce que
c'est un électorat qui vote pour leur
assemblée nationale est plutôt à droite
traditionnelle non mais c'était
difficile à dire je sais pas ce que vaut
cette dame je crois que ce serait se
rassurer à bon compte et j'ai
l'impression que beaucoup d'analystes
politiques se trompent parce que y'a un
côté rassurant si pour plein d'hommes
politiques
connues étiquetés en tant que tel de
reboiser moore c'est le front national
les cathos traditionalistes point final
on a mis le paquet en faire mais on
balance tout mais c'est pas vrai du tout
ça déborde bien évidemment de ce cadre
là non mais c'est faire abstraction de
ça c'est ne rien comprendre ou danger
enfin là aussi au schisme zemmour c'est
penser qu' il ne séduit pas que des gens
de droite et d'extrême droit bien au
contraire c'est ça le truc ça s'est
passé parfaitement exact c'est vrai que
la campagne possible candidature zemmour
puisqu'il n'est pas officiellement
encore et une candidature qui est très
transverses ans et kelly nous arrive à
séduire et pardonnez moi de vous faire
observer c'est peut-être dure réalité
des gens dans l'art large registre elle
va très largement sur l'échiquier
politique
sans doute de l'extrême gauche vers
l'extrême droite et il balaye il ya des
gens qui se retrouvent en zemmour parce
que ils ont même texte même d'extrême
gauche et même à gauche est position
concordante avec lui sur les thèmes les
grands thèmes qui sont les siens mais
cela dit le vote populaire le vote
ouvrier notamment ils étaient
majoritairement pour le rassemblement
national il est toujours d'ailleurs
à tel point que une partie de la gauche
a même théorisé l'idée qu'il fallait
plus aller rechercher le vote populaire
mais plutôt le vote des nouveaux
migrants etc il ya eu des études là
dessus bien c'est vrai je veux qu'elle
me rappeler une chose c'est que le tout
d'abord les bébés les classes populaires
s abstiennent est ce qu'on parle
toujours que le fn est le premier parti
du vote populaire c'est un vote
contestataire donc quand on est dans une
france notamment au nord par exemple des
territoires qui se désinscrivent
désindustrialise il ya plus de travail a
plus rien les gens ils contestent et qui
est kate est souvent été affichés comme
étant l'opposant à tout ça c'était
madame le pen et donc les gens voter le
pen mais pour autant la majorité encore
une fois des classes populaires elles ne
votent pas et donc via l'app store sur
vous avez donc ce côté de dire que les
classes populaires seraient
naturellement un peu de temps elle
tendrait de plus en plus réactionnaires
j'y crois pas vraiment
côté pros
du coup voter pour eux parce que c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui niveau atteint
native ailleurs elle n'existe pas
beaucoup ou atocas elles ne sont pas
beaucoup médiatisé en tout cas beaucoup
moins que les courants d'extrême droite
en général
est donc la conséquence est là mais pour
autant les classes populaires moi je
suis contre l'idée de croire en moi je
dis ça ce que dans ma ville où je suis
on fait beaucoup de porte à porte on va
parler aujourd'hui ralliement
une population qui est très mélangées et
ça se passe plutôt bien quand même à
guyancourt c'est comme dans beaucoup de
villes de banlieue en vrai à part
évidemment on peut toujours pointé les
deux ou trois moments où ça peut péter
un petit peu où il ya deux-trois
échauffourées mais la vérité c'est que
essentiellement tout au long de l'année
ça se passe bien globalement
non en tout cas les classes populaires
sont pas de plus en plus communiste ou
non elles sont pas a priori non elles
sont pas rattachés à un parti politique
c'est vrai dans tout ce qu'on leur parle
et quand on voit leurs idées après le
problème c'est qu'elles votent pas donc
même si elles me disent qu'elles sont
d'accord avec ce que dit l'édile
basculement et parce que
c'est vrai que le parti communiste n'a
pas su garder garder ce cet électorat de
base et l'a connue par les communistes
et la gauche en général parce que tout
le travail depuis 80 ans fait là les
différentes trahison de la gauche qui
ont fait que le l'espoir qu'ils avaient
dans la gauche est parti dans un vote
contestataire qui est parti en notamment
à l'extrême droite
alors est ce que disent les trahisons
puis 80 c'est à dire c de plus que la
gauche et gouverner au fond quel travail
et qu'ils n'ont mes souvenirs on peut
faire rêver quand on gouverne pas mais
quand on gouverne ont des rendez-vous
mais
excusez moi cette scène dames pourront
revenir la vida il avait diffusé elle
dit quelque chose de très intéressant
alors déjà si elle pense qu'elle pense
depuis 80 ans rue bancel observé qu'elle
est très bien et déjà j'étais bien dans
ma cellule à la haye la mode est
revenue un petit peu moins elle s'est
dit qu'elle ne pouvait peut-être pas
faire illusion dans sa face à la mer
la deuxième chose c'est qu'elle dit de
zemmour qu'il est très intelligent et en
ça c'est peut-être là où lui il est
capable d'aller chercher un autre
électorat que celui de marine le pen
mais parce que il y avait roulé sur un
nul 1 1 sur 10 effectivement il ya
toujours une frange de la droite qui
n'avait jamais enfin de l'électorat de
droite qui n'avait jamais cédé aux
sirènes de l'extrême droite parce que le
discours était peut-être trop brutale il
était peut-être trop abrupte qui n'était
pas assez intellectualiser il était trop
loin finalement des valeurs qu'elle veut
qu'elle cet électorat cherchait dans un
candidat politique il faut dire aussi
que marine le pen pâtit beaucoup de sa
prestation à brimont cataclysmique
débat d'entre deux tours et là où
zemmour lui arrive finalement à balayer
tout cela c'est qu'il a un discours
alors pas moins haineux mais peut-être
plus intellectualiser est peut-être plus
audible pour une frange de la population
une frange de l'électorat qui
viendraient chercher finalement certains
aspects théoriques plus que un discours
moins
brillé celui de marine le pen minimum de
culture
extrêmement important au sein c'est une
culture qui est contestable parfois
denses
mais mais ce qu'il ya c'est non ce qui
est assez intéressant d'ailleurs c'est
que au fond si on regarde comme rémy
prend plutôt
marine le pen si je peux dire par la
droite
et et il arrive malgré ça à séduire une
partie de l'électorat de la droite légal
mais c'est assez
c'est assez contradictoire presque mais
ça marche après après il faut dire aussi
que ans dans le paysage politique
français on n'a jamais eu autre chose à
l'extrême droite que la famille le pen
qui finalement est d'abord le discours
de jean marie le pen bron un moment et
bruno mégret bon qui est très clairement
a fait scission avec jean marie le pen
mais qui en était finalement une
émanation plus court et il n'y a jamais
eu aucune alternative à l'extrême droite
au discours de la famille le pen
s'étaient pas là ça arrive je rappelle
quand même que vous avez raison de
parler de maigret que c'est l'année où
il ya eu deux candidats d'extrême droite
c'est-à-dire migrer le pen que le pen
détail au delà du retour à la nature
donc faute voilà tension on pense aux
divisions de son fameux c'est vrai bon
après c'est vrai que cet avocat et l'ail
il peut y avoir de candidat du même camp
et peut-être quelqu'un on a des choses
qui est intéressant c'est que
vous évoquez le surgissement de de
zemmour mais en réalité ça fait très
longtemps qu'il est là ça fait très
longtemps quand il était encore chez
ruquier quand il était déjà chez ruquier
sont qui se bourrent on le connaissait
en fait là c'est juste qu'il a accéléré
à si vous voulez le mouvement mais
encore on connaît son discours on
connaît sa pensée et vous avez raison il
ancre son discours dans une histoire
alors on peut la contester mais ils
entre eux sont ni ce sont 10 comment une
histoire dans une culture il va chercher
des racines à celle où assez lointaine
alors de gaulle ont pas et peut-être
tout à l'heure mais voilà il s'inscrit
dans l'histoire c'est peut-être un grand
mot dans l'histoire de france c'est
peut-être ça c'est là dessus qu'il va
capitaliser chez les bourgeois comme on
dit en tout cas chez les personnes qui
laisse un match de la fin qu'est ce que
c'est la france voilà qu'est ce que
c'est il pose cette question là il
s'appuie sur des piliers alors qu'on
soit d'accord ou pas c'est pas la
question mais sur sur des piliers la
souveraineté l'histoire la grandeur de
la france et ça je pense que ça peut il
y met des mots alors quand cette dame a
dit ça fait que cinquante ans qu'on en
parle pas peut-être qu'elle a raison
c'est à dire que lui il a osé le faire
il a osé prendre ces c'était de ces
thèmes là alors après personne n'osait
plus y avait des voix là et donc lui lit
les prendre il y est la plus rentable ou
non vichy n'est plus un thème tabou lui
non la dernière en date moi ça me fait
plutôt rire mais enfin c'est de dire bah
là le nom kalpen modi t2 devrait
d'abord blanc bleu qua non mais il ya
plus que la boue une mêlée mais les gens
oublient assez vite ça parce que ce
qu'on retient d'un homme politique ou
d'un futur proche un possible candidat
c'est celle écume des choses c'est
l'idée qu'on s'en fait donc qui parle de
dreyfus et et ses paroles lamentable / /
/ pétain survie fini pour la majorité
des gens c'est totalement oublié savent
même plus ce que c'est c'est donc ça n'a
pas d'importance pour les gens c'est pas
que ça n'en a pas
en revanche quand il parle de son amour
de la france quand il parle du drapeau
français qu'elle veut c'est un truc été
complètement abandonné 2 e rappelle que
l'élection présidentielle ou ségolène
royal s'était présentée elle avait dit
je voudrais que tout le monde viendra y
ait un sens et c'est tout le monde
c'était foutu d'elle et en particulier
son mari à l'époque françois hollande
qui avait dit oh oui oui nous on en a un
chez nous les casser il est caché
derrière le frigidaire non c'est ce que
françois hollande futur président de
république avait osé dire quand on
parlait de rincon français donc lui là
dessus d'un wagon vous n'êtes pas obligé
d'être un fanatique pour quelqu'un qui
veut dire en français chez vous on est
pauvre on n'est pas obligé de dire qu on
obtenait coincé dans les folles
d'araignée du dur derrière le fait jean
r c'est indigne enfin je vais comme
aborde le sujet justement des rapports
avec l'extrême extrême droite et
justement je propose de voir quelques
extraits d'un débat qui a opposé qui
s'appelait zemmour espoir ou imposture
et qui oppose alors
d'une part aurait de l'as cannes qui est
polytechnicien énarque fondateur du club
de l'horloge et qui représentant d'une
droite
extrême et à ces antisémites ont enfin
on va le voir et il veut livrer des tice
et le pouvoir voulait interdire
notamment la musique dans les
landes et dans les médias publics c'est
un théoricien de l'art et immigration
et puis il est il a face à lui thomas
jolly que le président du parti de
partie de la france qui a été créée par
karl ans qui était un dissident du
rationnement de sial qui est plus à
droite que le que le que le ratio on
écoute un petit extrait le compteur
tourne et que là le compteur
démographiques et migratoires tourne et
que pendant que nous serons peut-être en
train de discuter des sexe des anges eh
bien nous serons dans quelques années
minoritaire dans notre propre pays donc
voilà à partir du moment où à candidat à
l'élection présidentielle quel qu'il
soit par leur migration parle d'
invasion migratoire de colonisation
migratoire islamique eh bien je pense
que c'est quelque chose de bénéfique
dans la vie politique française et
quelle que soit l'issue des élections
présidentielles à partir du moment où
ces thèmes essentiels sont mis dans le
débat public il faut absolument
promouvoir les personnes qui qui qui met
ces thèmes en valeur alors là la réponse
n'aurait de l'as cannes le point
important à signaler c'est que jamais
alors ça c'est incontestable le fourbe
zemmour n'a voté pour jean marie le pen
c'est eric son prénom dans le fourgon
bonjour bella je vous ai laissé parler
c'est ma part les jeunes suivent donne
une épithète quai d'accueil de mon choix
le fourbe et zemmour n'a jamais voté ni
pour marine le pen il nie pour jean
marie le pen à l'élection présidentielle
ni à toutes les élections législatives
sénatoriales
départementales régionales le municipal
pour un candidat les rênes voudrais
faire une jamais ce qui prouve le peu de
cas qu'il fait en réalité des migrations
de ce couteau sache depuis 1912 lorsque
tu 1984 et 4120 3184 avec la percée du
fn et jean-marie jack le vote était
secret sont ceux son parti vous avez des
informations jeunes et pauvres gens
m'attendaient jamais jamais jamais
jamais il n'a appelé à voter pour un
candidat et rennes va ouvrir fans
voilà cela dépasse
de la soudaine etc dote ses deux titres
qui ne représentent qu'eux mêmes ils
doivent fait aucune pièce de 4 mètres
carrés
dir ils se réunissent à deux ils ont
fait le plein de l'ordre de 2,2 l'an
groupuscule web qu'est ce que vous
voulez vous abonner encore un petit
extrait pour la bon la route
l'espère sinon je passe pas mais c'était
c'était de lescun qui disait il
reprenait ce que ce que dit zemmour dans
son livre quand ils déforment dominique
strauss kahn et et tariq ramadan et il
concluait ça montre qu'on a à faire un
oriental qui n'est pas assimilé en gros
qu'on va faire un juif parce que ça
voulait dire mais c'est quand même
intéressant pourquoi de l'extrême
extrême droite se meut comme ces
dissidents duration bassiste a le
soutien et moore c'est en tout cas ce
que je pense pas que ça pour ts qu'est
ce que zemmour est ce que je vais est ce
que c'est a plus ou moins oui
c'est un mois mais c'est tellement petit
médiocre et c'est nul n'est venu comme
suit 7 ans et de personnels attendent et
renaud camus 16 quand même important
celles comme le tigre et de théoriciens
du grand remplacement rennes renaud
camus au - delà du talent il est capable
d'écrire un livre voilà ce qu'est ce que
ces deux titres ce serait bien incapable
donc nous on veut franchement j'ai un
vrai
c'est intéressant que vous en parler
parce que j'ai été moi assez surpris de
voir qu'il avait fait son retour en
grâce sur une sur une chaîne de
télévision française il y à peu oui
alors que c'est sur ces news pour ne pas
là pour effectivement pendant
et c'est vrai que c'est ce retour en
grâce m'avait quand même fortement
surpris parce que et ça c'est quand même
aussi un autre exploit zemmour qu'il a
de lui avoir permis si finalement ce
retour le retour de ces idées au premier
plan parce que lorsqu'il ya vu
l'attentât alors
vous allez me rappeler la ville c'était
en nouvelle-zélande il me semble que
c'était pire c'était pittsburgh bon bref
je vais pas vous dire je veux pas vous
dire de bêtises mais un attentat qui a
eu lieu en nouvelle zélande sur la base
justement des théories qui avaient été
émises par renault cas sur le gros
remplaçant et à ce moment là il avait
été vilipendée par la communauté
internationale qui pour le coup lui
prêtait peut être moins de talent en
terme d'écriture en matière de en
matière de théorie et de théologie parce
que effectivement
c'était à cette époque-là très compliqué
et finalement eric zemmour a permis ce
le retour de cette idée deux grands
emplacements véhiculée par an nous camus
au premier plan ça c'est que soi même
aussi est absolument alors pour le coup
on peut être d'accord ou pas avec eric
zemmour il faut quand même lui
reconnaître cette vraie aptitude à faire
réémerger ddd des déçus des sujets comme
et des personnes et des personnes comme
sylvie une chape de plomb il sera là
dessus c'est donc qu'on pouvait pas
aborder ou de gens qui n'avaient pas
droit à la parole et c'est vrai que ça
leur donne ça est ce que c'est bien un
moment là bien pensants c'est peut-être
parce que c'est florence woerth est déçu
et je veux bien je voudrais dire deux
mots sur la question précédente j'ai pas
pu la m'exprimer sur rassurez moi je
pense que lui il a sauté dans le gouffre
du fait qu'il n'ya pas d'hommes
politiques qui sort du lot dans les
autres partis traditionnels de
traditionalistes et qu' il veut être
l'homme fort qu'on n'a plus dans dans
les autres partis ensuite je voulais
juste dire qu'on a quand même un peu
oublié que il a été condamné à plusieurs
reprises et ça à personne non plus même
s'il a purgé sa peine et même si mais on
a le droit à l'oubli mais pour autant il
a quand même été condamné sur des propos
tels qu'ils continuent à les tenir et si
vous me le permettez j'aimerais revenir
sur cette histoire de compteurs
migratoires et ou sur le fait qu' on
deviendrait minoritaire dans notre pays
et alors là je déplore le fait que les
journalistes soient pas capables de
reprendre les chiffres sur la migration
ou si je peux en deux secondes dire que
les entrées en 2019 ces deux cent
soixante douze mille personnes qui
arrivent quartier de séjour dont 92
mille étudiants donc c'est aussi bon
pour le rayonnement de la france
d'accueillir des étudiants étrangers je
parle des étudiants or le 1 il y en a 45
milles qui obtient un titre de séjour
parce que ils ont un lien avec une
personne française donc majoritairement
sur le mariage il y en a 43 milles par
le regroupement familial
donc il ya bien un droit la famille que
la france défend et il ya trente-huit
mille réfugiés ou malades qui viennent
se faire soigner en france
et les autres ce ne sont que 19 min et
donc si on prend le taux d'immigration
depuis dix ans la france a un taux
d'immigration de 0 4% et on est en
dessous du taux d'immigration de
l'europe qui est de 0,7 pour cent quand
on vient de dire qu'on est minoritaire
ça ce sont des chiffres que j'ai repris
dans le cours de françois héran qui est
professeur au collège de france et qui
est en charge d'une chaire sur la
migration et les problèmes sociaux sur
sur l'année 2020 2021 et quand on
regarde ces chiffres qui qui sont des
chiffres de l'insee et de l'oscd eux on
peut pas nous dire comment est ce qu'on
peut dire on va devenir minoritaires et
comment est ce qu'on peut dire que il ya
un flot de migration et je n'arrive pas
à comprendre que l'ensemble des partis
politiques puissent venir faire le sujet
majeur le problème des migrations c'est
moi qui pensais
ce que l'écologie est celle des
problématiques
qui sont extrêmement graves sur les
années à venir il ya un vrai challenge
et je pense que le problème est le sujet
majeur de nos politiques devraient être
celui ci et je ne comprends pas que on
les ipad dans sur ces chiffres et je ne
comprends pas qu'il fasse en effet la
course à l'échalote derrière par
l'extrême droite sur la problématique de
la migration quand un email je suis
complètement d'accord avec ce qui vient
d'être dit il ya aussi les chiffres de
l'insee qui sont sortis disant que
l'immigration rapporté plus d'argent
qu'elle ne coûtait à la france donc
c'est aussi une chance l'immigration et
aussi pour tout un tableau des métiers
que les français ne veulent plus faire
il ya aussi un besoin de main d'oeuvre
sur un métier que les gens ne veut plus
faire
les ôter le grand argument que tapie qui
dérive est sorti assez vous
j'aimerais que les les aimiez arrêtent
de travailler pendant quinze jours il
est à de la france quitte pas totalement
fou d'ailleurs un match aussi attaché à
cette idée républicaine de la nation par
l'adhésion est donc l'origine ethnique
et autres ne doit pas être prise en
compte dans la construction de la nation
on le voit bien d'analyser la face de la
france est construite alors après a
vraiment envie d'y aller si free yahya
yahya jammeh après on peut pas nier
qu'il ya un ressenti ce temps difficiles
comme la température via un bail à il ya
une question qui se pose est en contact
du sable de plomb qui est une famille et
nous allons par exemple de ghettos il ya
aussi que c'est un des problèmes c'est
vrai qu'il ya des quartiers ce qu'on
appelle les quartiers perdus de la
république ça existe quand même le maire
un mot tout à fait exact ils vendent
d'adhésion
il n'y a pas de problème d'immigration
si l'adhésion le tout problème de
l'immigration et qui a pas une adhésion
automatique c'est moins qu'on puisse
dire donc
il est juste là sur ce mode a désigné
par adhésion non c'est pas d'adhésion
parce qu'il faut aussi une république
derrière qui met nous par exemple il ya
plein d'endroits on se bat tu pars de
toute la france en général on se moque
des services publics restent dans les
quartiers on se bat pour que les gens il
a encore la poste qu'ils aient encore
l'école qu'ils aient encore le travail à
côté si les gens sont bien accueillis en
france et qu'on leur montre à quel point
la république est généreuse et qu'elle
est incroyable ah bah oui il y aura plus
adhésion que si on a une tendance
accueilli si mal que ça il n'y aurait
pas alors en dépit des défis il convient
de nous sortir il y aurait pas tant de
gens à vouloir rentrer que le plus de
gens qui veulent montrer que des gens
qui veulent sortir donc arrêtons de dire
que la france maltraite les gens qui
arrivent c'est d'une énormité passé et
hakim athlète a dénoncé faisant baisser
des fêtes tiendra vers est un peu le
résumé non c'est la seule chose c'est
que les chiffres ont été donnés songé
remet pas en cause mais on parle dit mme
dont on parle de l'immigration légale
c'est les personnes qui ont elles aussi
l'immigration illégale et ça les
chiffres mais on les a pas dans notre
nature mais apparaît donc malheureux
enfin il ya aussi ces chiffres la
prendre en considération non sur la
chaîne de la chape de plomb sur
l'immigration moi je suis un enfant de
la télé un enfant de des réseaux sociaux
j'ai quand même l'impression depuis que
je suis née qu'on parle d'immigration
tout le temps à tous et de la
présidentielle toujours la question des
migrations et sûrs donc moi j'aime pas
cette idée qui aurait apparemment d'un
coup il y aurait quelqu'un qui arrive
qui parle du tout non tout a déjà été
dit et il arrive tout ça marche bien
c'est parce que c'est tellement
imprégnés dans le débat à ce que les
médias parlent beaucoup et moi ça fasse
quelque chose que j'avais deux condamnés
et je suis tout à fait d'accord sur la
question des vrais pros l'émanation des
gens se disent il ya l'énergie chirac
l'énergie explose il ya toujours eu des
propositions et l'énergie que les gens
pètent toujours plus pour les quand ils
ont été au pouvoir ils n'ont pas fait
leur exemple à autre chose que ce que
l'impression que plutôt que parler des
vrais débats qui touche les français sur
leur pouvoir d'achat sur l'énergie qui
coûte de plus en plus cher on leur parle
d'immigration tout le temps et
finalement de pour moi c'est passé pas
là le problème on a parlé aussi des
énergies on est en plein compte 26 et
finalement on parle que des problèmes
d'immigration comme si le seul problème
qui avait en france et l immigration la
vérité c'est qu'il ya beaucoup oui la
france pour beaucoup de gens c'est un
problème ressenti vrai ou pas ressenti
mais reste un poil ne pouvez pas juste
dire oui on en parlait en arabe le même
ressenti aussi quand on l'entend dans
les médias leurs toiles 20h on nous
parle d'immigration on commence à se
dire même quand on vit au fin fond de la
france un mois j'étais à dieppe à dieppe
e-vote attendre pour se lancer pour le
fin fond de la france est libre il bah
oui mais c'est quand même des
territoires numériques haut de liste
d'ailleurs c'est intéressant et qui y
est à 100% pour les municipales mais les
boeufs et 30 % aux élections le seul
seule élection le fn fait moins de six
hommes ont fait 5 6% lors des
municipales la preuve que localement
quand on fait des bonnes politiques on
peut lutter contre le fn et la france
populaire elle veut ça elle veut aussi à
vous répondre à leurs problèmes
d'alimentation robe j'avais beau bébé on
était le 9 novembre qu'on parle de de
gaulle superstar met donc à parler de
mon livre a très vite bravo de
jean-françois prémont sur jean-françois
près que j'ai reçu ici pour son
précédent livre qui est un chroniqueur
hippique est devenu qui vit en normandie
sas passants dormant dire j non là ça se
passe au qatar et à paris nantes sort et
ça faire ou d'élections présidentielles
pas celle là mais voilà c'était ok tueur
à gages qui vous tue aider les candidats
à l'élection présidentielle merci
beaucoup on va le dire très vite jean
françois prévand sont aux éditions la
joie dit merci infiniment raphaël je
vous libère même si je vous attends oui
merci beaucoup
merci à tous et à très vite pour un
nouveau numéro de poche
[Musique]